when we think of the most volatile
assets within the financial space most
of us think about crypto despite
reaching a market cap of over 1 trillion
bitcoin still experiences 70 to 80
crashes on a regular basis within the
crypto markets these are actually rather
team crashes considering what happens is
they're not coins like luna but anyway
as you guys probably already know
bitcoin is currently experiencing one of
these bear markets having sold off 71
since november the most ironic part
however is that bitcoin has actually
held up better than some of the most
reputable and well-known businesses in
the world such as shopify since november
shopify is down at 82.6 percent and
let's not forget shopify is not some
penny stock or options contract they're
one of the biggest e-commerce players in
the entire world and at the peak they
were worth 228 billion dollars but now
they're only worth 38.5 billion dollars
this means that within 8 months shopify
has lost 190 billion worth of market cap
now of course you could argue that the
entire market is crashing and that's
true
but to my knowledge shopify is thus far
the worst performing large cap company
in the world
so what happened to shopify
one of the driving forces of shopify
over the past few years has been the
drop shipping bubble i mean how many
times have you heard about teens making
six if not seven figures on shopify and
let's not forget about all those drop
shipping and amazon fba gurus on youtube
now i'm not trying to say that all of
these guys are scams or that drop
shipping does not work drop shipping is
a viable business model and people who
really know the business will do well
regardless of how competitive it gets
with that being said though the vast
majority of people who are getting into
dropshipping aren't looking to start a
serious business
a lot of them are trying to make some
quick money on the side and this was
especially true at the beginning of the
pandemic in april and may of 2020 the
interest in shopify literally doubled
and it wasn't just entrepreneurs that
were interested in shopify investors
were also quite intrigued by the idea
most investors did not want to start
their own stores or anything but they
were quick to identify all of the extra
interest heading towards shopify and as
hopeful entrepreneurs call down on the
customer's side investors pulled on on
the investors side and it wasn't long
until shopify stock was sent to the moon
from the pandemic bottom shopify stock
would grow nearly 500 within a matter of
months while this likely felt super
rewarding to shopify investors this was
also completely unsustainable shopify's
pe ratio or price to earnings ratio went
to extreme levels of over 600
now it should be noted that shopify has
historically reinvested the vast
majority of their profits so their net
income is abnormally low which queues
their p e ratio but this issue does not
apply to their ps ratio shopify's ps
ratio or price to sales ratio also
skyrocketed to 53 to put that in
perspective even tesla only had a peak
ps ratio of 24 meaning that according to
this metric shopify was valued twice as
richly as tesla clearly this was a hyper
valuation that was just waiting to crash
and that's exactly what would happen as
the new interest in shopify fell off a
cliff here's the thing most people who
try drop shipping it don't actually make
it in fact nearly 90 of dropshippers
quit within the first month after not
making as much money as they originally
envisioned this number rises to 96
percent if we zoom out to the first six
months of business out of the remaining
four percent it's likely that a good
portion just continue to treat drop
shipping as a side business they might
make two or three thousand dollars every
month which is great supplemental income
but not enough to quit your job
especially given how volatile drop
shipping income can be considering this
only about one to two percent of drop
shippers actually end up becoming
long-term customers of shopify and this
becomes abundantly clear when we take a
look back at the google trends graph the
new interest in shopify died off as
quickly as it went up and as the hype
amongst entrepreneurs died off it was
just a matter of time onto the hype
amongst investors also died off
as new entrepreneur interest died off it
was only natural that shopify's
financials reflected that sooner or
later and that's exactly what's been
happening over the past few quarters
revenue and profit growth have slowed
down it and shopify expects these
metrics to slow down even more in the
coming quarters hearing that you'd
probably think that shopify's revenue
was down 50 or something but that's not
actually the case in fact shopify's 12
month revenue and the gross profit are
still higher than ever before not to
mention neither of these metrics have
ever gone down on a 12-month basis but
investors are fearful that shopify is
close to posting their first
year-over-year contraction if we take a
closer look at shopify's year-over-year
growth and gross profit you'll see that
this growth rate is lower than we've
ever seen shopify has historically
posted 80 to 90 growth quarter after
quarter but today this growth has
dwindled down to just 14
now i know that this makes a lot of
people in the comments quite frustrated
because it's completely unrealistic to
expect that a company grows forever 14
year-over-year growth is still a great
number from a fundamental perspective
but the thing to keep in mind is that
the stock had pricing over 50 annual
growth for years to come so a mere 14
was simply not enough to appease
investors something else to note is that
shopify's financials aren't as peachy
when we take a look at their net income
shopify's net income has never been
particularly high given that they just
reinvest everything but since the end of
2020 shopify's net income was finally
starting to reach respectable levels
until the last two quarters during these
quarters shopify lost 371 million
dollars and then 1.47 billion dollars
these losses can be traced back to a
couple of factors starting with
increasing operational expenses shopify
is spending significantly more across
the board sales and marketing has
increased from 186 million dollars to
303 million dollars research and
development has increased from 175
million dollars to also 303 million
dollars general and administrative have
increased from 67 million dollars to 108
million dollars and finally transaction
and loan losses have increased from 10
million dollars to 20 million
as you can see all of these operational
categories have increased by at least 60
percent meanwhile revenue has only
increased from 988 million dollars to
1.203 billion or roughly 21
it seems that shopify has yet to account
for diminishing growth and that they're
spending as if they were still growing
at 70 to 80 percent per year aside from
increasing operational expenses shopify
has also gone destroyed with their
investments given that they mostly
invested in hyper-growth companies like
affirmative global yi and silvergate
capital which are all down 70 to 90
percent such investments were the
driving factor buying shopify's external
losses of 1.55 billion last quarter
which left them with a horrendous
quarterly report
aside from the superficial factors that
are affecting shopify's stock price and
bottom line shopify also has a few
fundamental issues as well starting with
drop shipping today shopify has
basically become synonymous with the
drop shipping and honestly it's probably
where a significant portion of the
revenue comes from but shopify was never
created to support drop shipping the
purpose of shopify was to make it easier
for small merchants to set up an online
store but dropshippers aren't merchants
at all they're actually just marketers
who write orders to aliexpress this
might not sound like a big deal at first
glance but it is a big deal for two
reasons first of all people associate
shopify with fake gurus and get rich
quick schemes and secondly the products
that are sold on shopify are garbage
quality because all the money is being
spent on marketing now i'm not against
marketing by any means spending 20 of
your revenue on getting new sales makes
perfect sense as a business but
dropshippers generally spend over 50
percent of the revenue on marketing if
we have a 50 product for example this is
usually how their breakdown goes the
drop shipper spends ten dollars on the
product itself they spend at 30 on
marketing and then they keep the
remaining ten dollars for themselves
because of this a 50 product from
shopify is usually not even comparable
to a 50 product from a physical retailer
in terms of quality and longevity and
consumers are starting to notice
recently i posted a video about how
physical retailers are making a comeback
against online retailers and one of the
top complaints that i saw in the comment
section was that good from online
retailers were simply crash quality this
user commented i'd like to add that as
of today on amazon most categories are
flooded with the same chinese low
quality products but rebranded so for a
lot of items it's just quicker to find
them in a store and this guy was just
talking about amazon the quality problem
is exponentially worse on shopify and
this is no doubt ruining their brand
image one way that shopify is trying to
move away from dropshipping is by
growing their own logistical services
they're hoping that by offering small
businesses logistical capabilities they
can attract higher quality clients and
with the help of shopify these small
businesses would finally have the
opportunity to offer shipping times and
prices that are competitive with amazon
and walmart the only problem with this
is that it's basically just amazon fba
the idea itself isn't bad per se and i'm
not really worried about shopify being
able to attract enough customers the
real problem however is that developing
something like amazon fba is
extraordinarily expensive i mean amazon
launched the fba program in 2006 and
they've spent the past 16 years refining
every portion of the business but
despite this amazon still posted an
operational loss for the retail business
last quarter so clearly if shopify
doubles down on logistics they're not
going to be posting sideable profits
anytime soon meaning that the stock may
still have a lot of room to the downside
i know this video has been extremely
negative towards shopify but i don't
want to give off the impression that
shopify is struggling per se
yes the stock price has gotten
obliterated and they're experiencing
some painful quarters utilizing
operational expenses and some large
write-offs but in the grand scheme of
things shopify is still an e-commerce
giant and they're the go-to service for
creating online stores with that being
said though a lot of their growth in
recent years has come from drop shipping
which is not the best for their
long-term business after all i don't
think shopify wants to be an american
gateway to aliexpress their real goal is
to become small merchants best friend
and that's exactly what they're trying
to do with their logical services but
this is by no means a small undertaking
and it'll take several years before such
a plan produces returns in the meantime
shopify will likely post little to no
profits and in our current risk off
market that's basically a debt sentence
and i wouldn't be surprised if shopify
ends up selling off 90 to 95 before
finally bottoming if you're willing to
hold through this potential short-term
volatility however shopify will likely
be a phenomenal investment 10 years down
the line but that's just what i think
and it's not financial advice are you
guys a fan of drop shipping comment that
down below
also drop a like if you wish that online
products were under garbage quality and
of course consider joining our discord
community to suggest future video ideas
and consider subscribing see more
questions logically answered but until
then i'm hurry and i'll see you guys on
the next one
you